but now I get to introduce the next and
this is really our last it's not the
last activity of the weekend but it's
the last major thought panel and the
focus instead of being on us and what
co-education was like for us is much
more institutional what was Co education
what impact did it have what is it
continuing to have and to the extent it
we have a future looking panel hopefully
we will talk about what does Co
education mean today and even going
forward
I have the opportunity to introduce
someone who hasn't been introduced at
least four times so far so I'm going to
keep my comments a brief
Peter Salome is the 23rd president of
Yale he has been president since 2013
and I won't repeat anything more than to
welcome him up to introduce the panel
moderator thanks Thank You Barbara good
afternoon everyone I'm proud to be
president 23 I get enormous amounts of
clothings particularly athletic wear
with the number 23 on it as a result and
that's Michael Jordan and Kobe Bryant
so I tease Rick I always say well who
was 22 anyway I can't think of any 22
it's a really an honor to be able to
offer some introductory remarks for why
co-education matters matters at this
point in the 50th anniversary weekend
you have been a part of many crucial
discussions about how Co education began
at Yale what it was like for the first
Trailblazers who transformed this
university and this afternoon our
panelists will explore further the
meaning of this anniversary by examining
past present and future of co-education
I was thinking that it's hard to imagine
a Yale without women
so the Yale College without women
last May 659 of the 1,350 undergraduate
degrees awarded at commencement went to
women this fall of course we welcome
just as many women as men into the Yale
College class of 2023 by the way all of
those first years were wearing shirts
that said 23 on it and I I thought is it
this nice there-there's greeting their
president of course I had nothing to do
with me
further today today right now today
seven of the 15 Dean's of the
undergraduate professional and graduate
schools are women but in February as I
mentioned to some of you yesterday that
number goes to eight more than half with
the addition of dr. Nancy Brown the new
Dean of the Yale School of Medicine the
senior fellow of the Yale Corporation
who is on this panel is a woman but so
was the previous senior fellow and so
was the senior fellow before her don't
let the word fellow fool you
co-education has increased the
representation of women in every kind of
role at Yale in universities around the
world in government agencies businesses
and numerous other sectors as well the
women who led co-education who led the
efforts in the 1960s and 70s set the
stage for our efforts today to increase
representation of women in faculty
positions and in leadership roles across
all sectors
so these Trailblazers are the ones who
taught us you are the ones who taught us
how to have deeper discussions about
inclusion about diversity about
belonging for all individuals for people
of every gender and every way of
understanding themselves as we celebrate
co-education we look to a future that's
built on your work your triumphs your
experiences your wisdom
or what provide a foundation for
students on campus today and they helped
shape Yale and the world in the years
ahead so I have to thank you for the
contributions that you have all made
that have improved higher education and
scholarship and research especially here
at Yale but at institutions around this
country indeed around the globe and I
want to thank you those of you who have
remained interested in continuing to
further higher education especially the
promise that the co education of Yale
College presents to all of us
so it is a pleasure for me to introduce
the moderator of this afternoon's panel
Karen Lawrence from the class of 1971
[Applause]
Karin currently serves as the president
of the Huntington Library Art Museum and
Botanical Gardens in San Marino
California before that she was the
president for a decade of Sarah Lawrence
College she's a renowned educator
scholar a leader she typifies the
qualities that Yale aspires to inculcate
among our students so she will tell you
about the rest of the panel but join me
in welcoming her and our colleagues here
this afternoon thank you Thank You
president salary and it's a real
pleasure can you hear me okay I think
we've got the mics solved so that's good
it's a pleasure to be here and to
introduce our esteemed panelists I do
want to say as a graduate of 1971 that
it's been a pleasure to relive the
moments all together of our fishbowl
existence as it was called in the survey
and also and the previous panel was
fabulous in doing that and also to place
it in the cultural contexts in which its
embedded and Sam Chauncey's discussion
last night the fireside chat and also
the panel yesterday on Yale society in
the 60s I think really provided that
very important context I want to say one
personal thing about that I think for
most of us who were here Co education is
embedded in that context and for me it's
almost impossible to think about it and
my education without thinking about the
political education and Mayday and so I
just want to share one very quick
vignette I was in Davenport taking a
Davenport college seminar with Anna
Freud one of the 15 lucky
people students in Davenport who could
take the psychopathology of child of
childhood with Anna Freud and Silas Minh
and it was with ambivalence that I faced
that moment when everybody made the
decision and and she was going to leave
but I was reminded at lunch by one of my
roommates that the day before May Day
and I stayed and was involved in that
with other folks and the day before May
Day Anna Freud came and spoke to the
Davenport students about her experience
in the Blitz in World War two and we
gave her a Yale sweatshirt and my most
vivid memory is of Anna Freud putting on
a big sweatshirt with a why over her
dress and totally unselfconsciously
and smiling at everyone and then she
left and she left the Yale campus
understandably leaving at that moment
but for me those memories and for many
of us I think are very embedded in that
context so today we are going to look
back a little bit but really concentrate
as president seller they said on the
present and what's the unfinished
business of co-education both at Yale
and elsewhere and what have we learned
about it
you have the bios of our progressive
panelists in your programs they are
seasoned administrators I don't know
that I'm going to ask you for the
administrators point of view but I'm
sure fascinating though it would be but
we but everything that you've been and
done will be part of what you know and
your response I'm going to just focus on
their multiple connections to Yale and
experiences of almost different Yale's
that that they've had so copy or kathryn
bond hill is the former president and
the Vassar and currently managing
director
director of Ithaca SNR research and
consulting initiatives to broaden access
to higher education she received her PhD
in economics from Yale in 1985 at a time
when I'm betting you were one of the few
women in at least one of two women in
your classes she has the vantage point
of now serving on the board of Yale and
us and is successor in senior trustee of
the Yale Corporation and is professor
emeritus of president emeritus of Vassar
Kim goth Cruz experienced Yale as an
undergraduate about ten years after we
did she graduated in 83 and went to Yale
Law School and graduated from the law
school in 86 she previously served as
assistant dean in the college and
director of the afro-american cultural
center and now her vantage point is as
vice president for student life at Yale
and secretary of the Yale Corporation
Marvin Chun serves as Dean of Yale
College and is the Richard M Colgate
professor of psychology with
appointments in cognitive science and
the Yale School of Medicine Department
of neuroscience he's also served as head
of Berkeley College
I think dick broad head president
emeritus of Duke wins the award for the
most varied relation to Yale on this
panel at least he graduated from an
all-male Yale in 1968 and was a graduate
student and a teaching assistant and
then a faculty member all while we were
going through our education and served
long and very successfully as Dean of
Yale College and has the most
comprehensive experience I think of
different Yale's so let me I do want to
look back and I do want to talk about
that briefly that
transition and bringing to bear your
other experiences but certainly the
transitional experiences for you at that
moment well I've been thinking about
this and let me say you know listening
to me is to me always fascinating but
being here this morning and hearing
people tell all those particular
personal stories of where different
people found their friends where
different people found their
opportunities in their futures that was
just so fun so I'll just throw in my two
cents
I came to Yale in 1964 well maybe I'll
start this way I was president of Duke
for 13 years and while I was there
we spent a year and a half celebrating a
deeply significant fiftieth anniversary
the 50th anniversary of the admission of
the first african-american students to
do now you can say how is that possible
but it was a segregated state let's
remember and although I went to Yale at
the same time you know was not
segregated but there were ten black
students in a thought in a class of a
thousand when I was there so it was
something it was something now the
interesting thing is when say when Duke
was integrated for college students in
1963 this was after there had already
been 10 or maybe even 15 years of very
active agitation about the issues of
racial exclusion not only on the Duke
campus but it but across the South in
Durham itself had been a center of this
agitation going back to the early 1950s
now I put that in my mind and I compared
it to what it was like to raise the
subject of the admission of women to
Yale in 1965 6 7 and here's why I got to
tell you you know I was a smart person
my classmates were smart people but you
know I just will admit it to you when I
came here I did not come here because it
was an all-male school or in hopes that
it would soon become educated you know
my classmates understood that Yale was
all-male it had already been for 200 and
what do the math 263 years by the PI by
that point so was every other school we
would have gone to if we hadn't gone
here and so if you asked a male student
at that time why does Yale not have
women the answer would have been I think
just or more positively why does he have
at MIT only man I think the answer would
have been because it does because that's
just the way it is none of us I think
thought much more deeply about that
if you had said any member of my class
that Yale it made it only man because it
had a mission to produce a thousand male
leaders we all regarded that phrase with
great scorn and dripping sarcasm
whenever we mentioned it so here was a
place that was all-male why because it
just was that was true in my freshman
year I do not remember a discussion of
the subject in my freshman year I don't
remember a discussion in my sophomore
year I can remember the beginning of
discussions in my junior year and then
it falls in the category of things that
went from being unthinkable to mandatory
without ever passing through the phase
of reflection all of a sudden me and
everybody I knew understood that it was
now totally wrong for this place to be
exclusive of women and then it had to
admit women as quickly as possible
I it was in my senior year the
co-education week took place obvi cypher
later taught my wife constitutional law
he's a you know I knew him we we all
participated in it and people in my
advantage
believe that the reason Yale Co educated
is because it was about to be co
educated by its students if it did not
because it make the administrative
concession to the fact so so there it is
it went from unthinkable to has to
happen and sure enough it happened very
quickly thereafter but so now I just you
know we but by now you've heard the
reasons why Yale co-education Nancy
Malkiel gave a very thought-provoking
and I believe historically accurate
strategic account of the
administration's logic and I could give
and you could give an account based on
morality and social justice or even the
social policy of yal needed to
co-education
but I'm just going to give you the
reasons why it was important to a young
man who was a student at that time and
there'd be two there'd be twofold one if
you went here you had a lot of great
male friends but friendship with women
was an unknown phenomenon really pretty
much that's true if you think about it I
had also gone to an all-male school for
four years before I came here you're
used to schools being all-male and then
occasionally something happened in
college that never happened in boarding
school which is buses would arrive and
women would arrive and they would go up
the stairs and then you go and ask them
to dance and whatever you could possibly
accomplish beyond that point and then
it was all over and as I say I mean I'd
have to say no one regarded this as fun
at the time it was very distasteful
there was something you know I don't
want to use the word but it's not too
strong a word there was something
debasing not only for the victims of it
but for oneself as well and I did not
regard road trips I mean you know Vassar
meant
road trips and I did not regard road
trips as that much more fun either um it
was just the nature you know to read The
Scarlet Letter remember what Hester
Prynne wants to do at the end she wants
a utopian colony where someone will
understand how to put the relations of
men and women on a surer ground of
mutual happiness that's what he'll
needed at that point the relations of
men and women were on a ground of total
abnormality total unnaturalness and and
so it seems to me I'd have to say in my
own personal life reaching a state where
women could be just your friends where
they could know you just as you and you
could know them just as now that was
actually something it took co-education
to produce in Fisk University by chance
I believe I attended the first fully
co-educational college when I was a
senior I had to take Latin because I was
going to go to graduate school and you
had to have have passed tests in many
languages so I took first year Latin as
a senior but the class was filled with
women in the graduate school there to
pass their language requirements who
were graduate students in music and
French Nancy Vickers friends were in
this were in this class and I thought
all of a sudden you're in a class where
half or more of the students were women
and you know we just became friends and
that was the beginning of a whole new
chapter of maturity in in in my
education so it seems to me in some
sense it was about humanizing life for
co-education but then I discovered a
second reason that I still wouldn't have
been aware of in 1968 you've heard the
strange but this arranged fact I entered
graduate school in the fall of 68 my my
classmates were at least half women
there and I immediately had many women
friends including one who I married the
the the that fall it was announced that
Yale would admit women the following
fall women were admitted
and the following fall I drew my first
teaching assignment now please keep in
mind I am a person who would only ever
wanted to do one thing on earth and
that's probably still true which was to
be a college teacher but I never done it
you know and so all of a sudden in Alvin
Kern and Shakespeare class I had to lead
a discussion section of my first class
but by that point the class already had
a significant number of women Olivia
Whiteman is here somewhere where are you
there you are you were in my class is
there anybody else who was in that class
where are the rest of you yeah you who
are you yell me your name
I might have been alright so this room
contains my actual and my potential
students okay but anyway
but here's the funny thing so when I
started teaching of course you know this
was a discussion section it was not a
lecture so you went in and tried to ask
interesting and provocative questions
and right away you found this is a piece
of cake because people would just raise
their hands and plunge in and begin to
discuss all these interesting things but
I'd have to say the discussions in that
class were different than they had been
when I had been an undergraduate two
short years before in all-male Yale I
never was a student in Akko educated
Yale and I never was a teacher in an
unco educated Yale but right away in
that class you saw you know women light
class discussion they raised their head
they plunged right into it the students
in my class nothing reminded me of them
so much as hearing the people on the
panel this morning all that vitality all
that articulate miss all that confident
the confidence it just desire to go in
and get at it and you know it had the
funny thing which is it actually made
men behave differently in class
discussion because male Yale up til 1968
was under the tyranny of very oppressive
stereotypes for men within the college
one of which is it's good it's good to
be intelligent but it's not good to care
too much about it it's good to be
intelligent but not good to be
intellectual and so there was a kind of
pose of what shall we call it relaxation
gentlemanly leisure
I could if I would you know what I'm
talking about and actually the
interesting thing is once the class
started and men were occupying the pose
of gentlemanly leisure and women were
making all the interesting points that
wasn't gonna last very long and soon the
men discovered that they not only wanted
to do this too but could do it too and
I'd have to say I'm not sure this point
has been made as deeply as I would make
it the deepest change that co-education
made for Yale is that it made it an
academically vibrant and vital place for
its undergraduate
[Applause]
I would never let me say what don't show
me the yellow card yet I've got one more
thing to say no yellow card just just
just one more thing and in those classes
the whole point is all of us on you had
women in the classes the point has been
made many times no one was ever there to
be called on or to speak the woman's
point of view it would never have
occurred to me to ask a student to say
that nevertheless if you have excluded
half of humanity from your class before
this point you may be sure there's going
to be points of view now president that
used to be absent and so it was not only
the vibrancy but also the fullness of
consideration that was changed there and
then I remember something that happened
in my second year and I'm trying to make
eye contact with Margaret Homans if I
you know feminism came together with
co-education into the life of male
students at Yale and an interesting
thing is I couldn't remember teaching
did any of you ever take English 25
Chaucer or Spenser Milton there's a poem
by Pope that we all used to teach called
Epistle to a lady on the character of
women remember its first line nothing so
true as what you once let fall most
women have no character at all and then
it goes on and it's a very witty
brilliant poem at the end of the class I
remember a student I'll tell you her
name though I do not know her since she
graduated Judy fabricant was her name
very smart she raised her hand it said
nevertheless what do you think of
somebody who would say nothing so true
was what you learned let fall most women
have no character at all and you know
just all of a sudden I'd have to say at
that moment you saw the scales fill from
your eyes and you realized the implicit
selectivity the implicit limitations of
the things that had been taken for
granted as true by everybody up to that
point that was the biggest later changes
but this is the variant amar of the
curriculum and how it changed with women
but I do want to
in a couple of the panels we were
talking about when Yale changed and I do
want to ask actually whether one of the
things that emerged of the cultural
context was that there were more public
school men who came to Yale leading up
to co-education who might not have found
it as bizarre to have women in the
classroom and so I just kind of want to
ask ask about that point just know that
there were antecedent conditions Oh
clearly they were to be hired from
Midwest schools where the the thing is
in the class of 67 was the first class
that had a majority of public school
matriculants there had been as many as
65% from private schools from private
boarding schools and I think at one
point I heard more than 50% of Yale
students used to come from the same
eight schools I went to end over there
were 45 people from my high school class
in my freshman class when I came here
guess what the next year there were 22
from that school and it never reached it
never reached such a high number again
and surely that change helped it it's
all part of a larger change but never
I'm just describing my personal
experience of it thank you
when when we talk about co education I
think Sam Chauncey was quoted in their
recent alumni magazine as saying people
keep talking about co education is if
this was some magical thing that never
happened before anywhere else and we're
here because it was crucial to us to the
institution that is what we're talking
about it is true that in 1955 75% of all
colleges and universities enrolled both
male and female undergraduates and that
often comparisons are made and there's
wonderful literature on comparisons
between elite men's schools and
sometimes in the literature comparisons
about the benefits of co education for
women
versus single sex education so these are
parts of the discussion I want to turn
to Kathy who was the president of a
college that went co-ed the other way
around and admitted men as a minority to
a majority female campus and just and
and I share that with you as Sarah
Lawrence
Vassar received Yale's proposal as did
Sarah Lawrence
I mean rejected Gail's proposal as Sarah
Lawrence rejected Princeton's can you
talk a little bit about that process and
outcome so it's been wonderful to be
here and it was so interesting to hear
people this morning my own personal
experience is actually more similar to
yours I was in the second class of all
women at at Williams College which moved
to co-education a little bit more slowly
than Yale but not by much of some my
entering class was the fall of 72 and I
graduated in 76 so very a lot of very
common experiences and then I went back
to Williams to teach and was provost and
then went to the bastard position when I
went from Williams to Vassar of course I
dug into the archives to find out about
this period of time when both Williams
went co-ed and Yale went co-ed and
Vassar went co-ed and it was really fun
to learn a little bit about the history
it had really started in the early 60s
and in the archive so you could see the
presidents starting to really worry
about what was going to happen as it was
clear the demographics were changing and
what students were interested in was
changing as well I wouldn't get to town
in time to hear Nancy's talk yesterday
but we actually talked quite a lot when
she was working on her book because she
was trying to dig into the Vassar data
on what happened to the the student body
during this period of time so anyway I
learned a lot about Vassar going co-ed
and and just some some interesting
stories I think very early on when I was
that faster I was meeting with the class
of 69 and they were the last all-female
class at Vassar about which they were
quite proud but it was so interesting
the first time I met with them because
they were very divided on what the
path was for Vassar some of them were
just completely appalled by the notion
that that Vassar would have merged with
Yale some of them were quite appalled
that it was going to go co-ed and some
of them just were really sad that they
didn't get a chance to have a Yale
degree so it was this very mixed history
of that class so faster goes co-ed it
goes co-ed for many of the same reasons
that Williams did which was that it was
clear and I think Nancy's book makes
this point that the world had changed
and it was going to be very hard to
survive in an isolated community as a
single sex institution what it did at
Vassar was changed the pool of students
who were applying to go there before if
for for many of you I think many of you
actually started at one of the the
women's the Seven Sisters and then
transferred you didn't have the option
of going to Princeton or Yale or
Williams or a Merce once those
opportunities arose you made a more
decided decision about what kind of an
institution you wanted to go to and I
would say that what happened at Vassar
was that the applicant pool changed from
women who would have applied to
Princeton or Yale or Williams Ramage if
it were an opportunity to women who
wanted to go to an elite private
nonprofit institution with wonderful
faculty but that had a history of being
a woman's college and wanted to be at an
institution that was less masculine in a
way so the pool changed to women who
were more self-selecting to go to Vassar
the male students that were coming I
would say were similar in the same way
they were making a decision that they
wanted to go to an institution that was
not as masculine as some other
institutions now that this opportunity
was available and they fell into a
variety of I think different different
camps we had a longtime admissions
director who was really a wonderful
person who was there for quite a long
time he's passed away so I feel okay
telling a story about him but he talked
about the the
applicant pool of young men often being
young men who you know had been bullied
in high school by more mass by by other
men or young boys at that point and
wanted in an environment that was not
like that and so I think we ended up
with a much more selective applicant
pool both on the on the part of men and
women who wanted the kind of environment
that a college that had had 150 years of
educating women was going to be a
comfortable environment which suggests
that there's something in the DNA that
carries on from the history of having
been in all women's college and that
might also suggest that the same thing
happens in a in a college that goes
co-ed and admits women I think we've
been talking about going co-ed as if
it's an arrival or a destination but in
fact it's a process so I'd like to turn
to Kim and Marvin to ask about is that
is that DNA still at Yale in some sort
of palpable way in terms of the
unfinished business of co-education or
is there a sense of that for students
today good afternoon thank you all for
coming I really enjoyed the sessions
yesterday and today especially the one
this morning it's very inspiring for me
and my role is Dean to hear about our
histories and to see you know your
adventurous and your resilient selves
really forging a path for Yale to be
what it is today which I do think is a
really outstanding place for educating
all our students I'm looking at my name
card over here and I look very under
educated everyone else has all these
fancy credentials but I wanted to point
that out because I there is one
credential that's missing here which is
that I'm a parent my daughter is a
junior here and and so I get to see what
an incredible place Yale is through
through
[Applause]
and you know for me the value of
co-education really just rests on the
fact that if we are if our student if
our faculty
if we as a community if our mission is
to serve the world then we really need
to look like the world and and it kind
of really everything really boils down
to that a very simple fact and with
regards to unfinished work I think of
course we've made amazing progress and
Yale now is very very different from the
Yale I've been hearing about over the
past two days but but there's still work
to do
I think one area is that we do need more
diversity in our faculty right we came
up in discussion yesterday that 32% of
our latter faculty in the Faculty of
Arts and Sciences are women and which
made its which is great progress it's as
high as it's ever been but of course
what and that's still quite distant from
50% but there's a aspect of those data
that's very promising and Dean Tamar
Gendler here I can say more about it
perhaps with a very promising aspect of
those data is that it's 32 percent
because that's the entire faculty you
know ranging from recently PhD to people
who've been here for 30 40 years if you
just look at the cohort of new faculty
who arrived here in the past 10 years
45% of those of the new faculty are
women so I think the trends are looking
very good thanks to the good efforts of
our of our president and and Dean
Gendler and and these are I think this
is very important for our student body
which of course has parity to have a
faculty that looks that represents what
the students are like in terms of
another challenge for undergraduate
students 47% of our stem students are
women so so that's a you know there's
but but you may know that still women
representation in stem is low around the
country and this is a number that we
have to keep stay focused on there are
still some fields where the proportion
of women are even are lower than 47% and
that's been a that's an important
priority for me to raise in my role as
dean so first of all um I did graduate
ten years after you and so it's actually
wonderful to be able to see the
shoulders that I that I'm standing on in
person so it's been really wonderful to
hear your voices and I'll spend all the
day with the day with you to hear some
more about your stories I also have the
privilege of being secretary and also
vice president for student life here and
that means that I'm very focused on the
student experience largely outside of
the classroom so I like to say that I
focus on where students eat sleep play
pray and pay outside the classroom is
fine and I think I think about that for
all students not just the college but
all students on campus but having been a
member of the college both in the dean's
office and also I worked for dick
actually and also an undergrad I do have
a special place in my heart for the for
the undergraduates that I work with and
the leadership that I work with I think
that what we would say to you in terms
of and I'm now channeling a lot of their
voices is that YESCO education has
worked in terms of the diversity in
terms of the number but we are all
focused on issues of equity inclusion
and belonging and what we are what that
means is that we are focused on making
sure that all of our students have equal
opportunity here in ways that that focus
on the legal definition of legal equity
but also that they are they feel
included that they always feel as if
they have opportunities that are
meaningful for them and that they belong
which means they can be their authentic
self and so a lot of our student leaders
particularly women leaders are focused
on those aspects of what it means to be
at Yale and feel that although we have
made progress that's some of the areas
that we really need to focus on
I think of title 9 as being one of the
issues that many of our students and we
have to name that because that is
something very much in our students
right now in terms of the campus climate
which has improved and which we are all
stealing still working on including I
think of very much this this group of
young women being multi - it's and
intersectional that they are very much
focused on gender and because they
always think of themselves as being
multiple multiple and holistic in their
view and so what does that mean in fact
just this week they talked to me that
women leaders talk to me about making
sure they could see themselves in a
variety of ways and not just as women so
we can have more conversation about that
but I think the co educate the
demographic piece we have done well at
Yale College but I think it's the
inclusion of more the belonging piece
that we are now all focused on student
leaders and the rest of us in terms of
making this the best the best experience
for these young women - to the to have
here great there are two directions I'd
love to go in relation to what you both
have said one is actually to follow up
on your experience Mormon as a parent
and the sense of the climate with the
daughter here and I've been talking to
people and that's something we haven't
really talked about is the experience of
the children of our class and whether
that's you know how they experience and
now I guess I am asking you to speak for
your daughter and I was asking people
not to speak for someone else but I'm
interested in in in that and maybe from
the audience if there's any comment
about the kind of climate or in the DNA
of a school its history or have your
daughters or sons felt a very different
obviously a very different environment I
mean there's no question but anybody
want to yeah Susan Susan waste Bryn from
our class of 71 I have two daughters who
are in graduate programs here in the art
history program and then a resident at
the medicals
and what struck me is something that I
struggled with when I was here which was
I wanted the opportunities of being a
man but I didn't want to live my life as
a man in terms of my career and watching
my daughter's now who are young mothers
as well they're being crushed by the
amount of responsibilities that they
have and I say to them now that you're
50% doctors now that you're you know 50%
almost professors you need to stand up
for how can a woman be a mother and also
her career and not have four overnights
a week so the advantages and some of the
tribulations that come from those
opportunities
I don't know Marvin if you want to say
anything else about the next generation
that over 50 years and in fact even in
the past 10 years we continue to evolve
and try to make this a more inclusive
climate one area that seems now very
natural but definitely it did not exist
10 years ago is that our housing is
gender neutral now and so the bathrooms
have always been gender neutral I mean
or unshared but the housing is the
configurations themselves have gone
gender neutral over the past ten years
recently extended to first-year students
as well so we continue to evolve in that
sense I'm gonna choose not to represent
my daughter because she doesn't like
that but but but in general speaking
again with my administrative hat I think
progress continues to be made challenges
in areas where we still need to work on
they're still gendered they're still
exist gendered social spaces on the
bright side organizations groups like
the Whiffenpoofs have gone co-ed last
year as I'm sure many of you are aware
but there are still many singing groups
that are that are single sexes there are
still Greek organizations that are
single sex so
these are areas that we have to continue
to attend to and I would say I think
going to your specific story is what you
see a lot in this particular generation
of young women in the college is
conversations about balance and wellness
so it as a generation they have really
been focusing on how best to manage
their time and their energy they are
also talking about the concept of ever
effortless perfection and trying to sort
of kill that dragon at the same time so
we spent a lot of time developing
programs that address that issue in fact
Laurie Santos had a course a couple of
years ago called the psychology of the
good life and but we have built the good
life Center in silliman College if some
of you have a chance to look at it which
basically offers classes that help you
make a decision about how you're going
to manage your time and your energy but
also how do you manage your life and how
you think things through
so there's ways in which this generation
is just much more focused on making sure
it's certainly thought about the college
now now your students are a little bit
older than them but the college the
young women are much more focused on
trying to make sure they have a balanced
life and it also raises the question of
professions yes and coming being at Yale
as a graduate student I mentioned so you
were one of two cabby in economics but
the how do we need to see our discussion
of undergraduate co-education within a
lens that includes professions that
women enter and the different times the
the different time periods where various
fields admitted women had more women I'm
hoping we'll continue to see things
evolve over time
and I think as we have more women
faculty coming up through the ranks as
we have more women lawyers more women
doctors that that they will start
thinking about the workplace and making
sure that it's a place that's
comfortable for not just women but men
as they try to have lives outside of
their professions I'm seeing amongst the
I have three kids who were all in a not
quite there yet but thinking about these
issues both two boys and a girl and and
they care about balance all of them do
and so I think this generation is going
to bring those values into the workplace
and that's what we need them to do to
make it more reasonable for both men and
women to lead lives that work so Kim I
want to follow up on what you said about
gender fluidity and a whole I mean again
the word the term co-education
presupposes binary or mostly presupposes
that and as you pointed out on college
campuses today there's a very different
discussion vocabulary and climate around
sexual identification gender
identification how does that how do we
need to think about that in relation to
the discussion about co-education well
we think about it certainly in terms of
as Marvin mentioned gender-neutral
bathrooms we saw the all gender
bathrooms right down there down the hall
and how do you negotiate that when you
have multiple generations some of us
actually still want men and women's
bathroom so how do you manage that with
students who are looking for something
different but we also have we're looking
at things very basic things like you
know how do we account for someone's
gender changing gender or their gender
identity on class lists because they're
generated very much by you know our
database and how do we how do we help
faculty understand who is in front of
them how do we help faculty understand
the person whose name that might be
legally Michael might be Michelle at
some points we've got systems in place
we've designed to make sure that the an
accurate identity is is in front of the
faculty members and we are actually
doing a lot of training with faculty and
staff and students about transgender
students which is a very big component
of the population of students a student
issues on campus on across the country
so we're always thinking about gender
broader than just male-female even in my
reports that I get from from my staff
about you know who's in the room and
they give me a list of
of students I might meet will they'll
say something like well we have four
people presenting as male so even our
language has shifted in terms of how we
address the issue but it's certainly our
policies are our programs and even if
some of our buildings are sort of
addressing that so we've got to be much
broader in terms of how we think about
these issues let me throw that open to
anyone else on the panel to talk about
intersectionalities and fluidity of
gender and and just the way of thinking
about who comes to the college and
inclusion and how they feel included
intersectionality and inclusion are
interacting and overlapping but by no
means identical issues it seems to me
Kathy is one of the most famous people
in the country associated with the idea
of promoting inclusion and I'd have to
say anybody who said nowadays you know
was co-education over was it
accomplished when women took up their
places as students yes and no right it
was and it wasn't it was it was because
they were here it wasn't because Yale
needed to be remade to become the place
they would be fully able to live up to
their highest potential and but I think
I think anybody who lived here at the
time realizes the the deepest thing
co-education did to Yale is to induce
the habit every so often of looking at
the university and asking yourself I
know it's great but is it really
misplace really serve the mission it
push push forward in the world and at a
certain point
Yale couldn't answer that question when
it excluded women and so women were
included certainly it happened the same
with the question of race in a
significant way also in the late 60s and
early 70s and you know now of course we
are all much more preoccupied with
socioeconomic questions now that we know
the very high correlation between family
income level of from birth to going to
college prep reparation over preparation
grooming that people get and how those
correlate and so I think that's really I
think as someone who was but until very
recently a university
I would say that's been the new horizon
the main new horizon of their Co
education opened up for us it's just and
the thing is even when that is solved to
our satisfaction I hope after about five
years people will say alright we've
reached the stage of self-satisfaction
again now let's ask the question again
is this place actually open to all the
people it has a mission to serve I think
just one of the real challenges on
college campuses is getting students to
listen to each other and as our
communities become significantly more
diverse just one of the real advantages
of being here for four years is to learn
from people that have had different
experiences and sometimes I think
there's a tendency to to not let that
happen and to choose one identity and
and feel like you need to somehow defend
it and and I think certainly my time at
Vassar was reminding students to take
advantage of the amazing diversity of
the campus and not only speak up but
listen to their peers about their
experiences as well I want to open it up
now for for questions for the remainder
of our time so we have about 20 minutes
for questions
yeah hello I'm Susan Kearney a Kuei 1971
Calhoun I wonder whether any thoughts
been given at Yale and addressing
co-education values through
modifications of traditional pedagogy we
know that co-ed and all-male classrooms
the dynamics are quite different from
all-female classrooms we also know that
female instructors are challenged much
more frequently both by both male and
female students that are male
instructors and finally we know that the
traditional pedagogical model at Yale
the sage on the stage well usually a guy
in a tweed jacket something like that
maybe a self a woman who is
that model maybe suits a kind of
masculine culture but may not bring out
the strengths and a feminine culture or
something in between
so my question I think going beyond the
question of how to retain the best women
instructors to build a truly diverse
faculty what is being done to examine
pedagogical models that are popular at
Yale I'll only say this and this may be
too ancient history I don't know they
remember the old joke I heard when I
came to Yale
how many alleys does it take to screw in
a lightbulb one to screw it in and one
to kick out the stool underneath him
while he's trying to do it when I came
to Yale I was really stunned at the
level of brutal competition finding
pages and books razor doubt that had
been left on reserve in cross campus and
so on and that there were no rules when
it came to winning
I'm assumed that's moderated over time
but the kind of valorisation
of that kind of competition and the
valorisation of a highly authoritative
professor I think speaks to a kind of
DNA at Yale that may need some
examination so what do you think well I
wonder if I could pitch into this I
you've just described a Yale I've been
here all that time right until I was
here for 40 years from my first freshman
day until and until I left the faculty
the Yale you describe of the man
knocking the stool out from another it's
not one I ever knew I never experienced
that kind of that kind of
competitiveness at this place
I think if women had come to a place
that had that culture it would have been
very different and I bet even that would
have had a modifying force in it but
don't forget as for the model of
pedagogy you know let me just say I was
a department chair I was a Dean the
greatest lecturers in my department
included both men and women the greatest
seminar Susy Wofford is in this room
your your classmate who was such a great
one then
Tamar Gendler agree a great a great one
of more modern vintage but the great
majority of VL instruction is done in
small groups where that's it and and
where it does not and small groups never
work if it's all me me me on the part on
the part of the faculty finding a way to
be gifted at seminar instruction is one
of the really powerful things
universities teach students because it
has to do how do you find an interesting
question and then how do you create the
space where different people can hazard
some portion of the answer and learn
from each other that's a great thing
universities teach people and it seems
to be the small group culture it was
what strong from my earliest days on the
faculty and I believe is probably even
stronger now I also think there's a lot
more emphasis on helping faculty think
about pedagogy so that their classroom
can be supportive for everybody that's
around the table that that was not
something that you've learned in
graduate school when I was here but now
it is something that institutions are
much more conscious of and I just want
to say there were 30 people in the econ
ph.d program the year I came to women
it was incredibly supportive and I loved
every minute of it
so I also did not experience that and
and other PhD programs had other
reputations and so part of the reason
for coming to Yale was precisely because
it did not have that reputation I just
have to add in Abunda the I think we're
very fortunate that our reputation and
higher education especially amongst this
generation of students is that we are we
are a strong community we are a
collaborative community we are
supportive of each other so so this
competitive notion I think really lives
in the past I also want to add that
we've we've done we do surveys not
surveys sorry we and now we analyze the
effectiveness of teachers and how
students view their teachers both for
small classes and large classes and so
and on average our women faculty
actually received numerically higher
ratings from the students and then the
men male faculty do if we if we break it
down by that by gender the second thing
I'll say is that regarding the kind of a
big authoritative large
lectures this is course by Professor
Laurie Santos is the largest in Yale
College history and and and and and so I
think it's because of her charisma and
the respect that students have for who
she is that has led to its its size even
this semester the largest class is
taught by women my wife and even though
she's going against at the same time a
distinguished male professor Akhil amar
of constitutional law so so I think I
think the culture is pretty good and
also just so you know that right across
the street is the physical manifestation
of our commitment to pedagogy which is
the Porvoo Center for teaching and
learning which does a lot of training of
faculty about new ways of teaching and
experience of learning and how to deal
with people who are introverted so all
kinds of ways of making sure the class
dynamics are really rich because if they
weren't we would probably be getting as
many students as we as we are that that
is our you know our commitment yes so
there's been a lot of change in the way
on multiple campuses how people are
changed trained in pedagogical you know
in to think about that and teaching but
I have to say I think that Yale has
always been focused on undergraduate
teaching in a very real authentic way as
part of the university it's not a place
where the only thing that faculty cared
about when we were there and now is
research and not how that enters into
the classroom and what happens among
students yep back there
[Music]
did you hear that I have a question not
a speech and I'd like to direct the
question primarily to Kimberly into mark
Marvin is that right we have the rise of
the cultural centers but what mechanisms
are we actively using to promote civil
discourse among the different cultural
components of the student body that goes
back to Kathy's question as well Kim so
one of the things we've been focusing on
the last year and a half is what we call
training students on how to have
difficult conversations and this is one
of the things that actually came up from
the student body we have an advisory
group of talking about what did some of
the issues we should be dealing with and
this one of the things that they all
seem that say that we need to be
focusing on Marvin and iron actually
mostly Marvin's going to start working
with a group of faculty members to come
up with some programming very specific
programming including classroom
hopefully classroom work to help
students interact differently with each
other but the students themselves are
actually coming up with informal ways of
educating each other about different
issues we are actually promoting
conversations with different viewpoints
on the same platform because typically
what happens mostly because of it's
difficult to get to pay for multiple
speakers on the same platform we're
trying to make sure that students have
the money to be able to do that so they
tend them by one person at a time we
would like to have three or four people
of the same topic coming from different
perspectives so you'll see that a lot
more so we're paying a lot more
attention to that so you'll think you'll
see more in the next couple of years
particularly given the the social and
political climate we feel it's very
important to double down on those kind
of skill sets for students and so with
student leadership Marv and I are trying
to work that work on that now thank you
for your question thank you and just to
add a little you know we're fortunate
here at Yale to have the most powerful
mechanism for promoting learning from
each other and civil discourse which in
my view is the residential colleges
because we force
[Laughter]
because we require students to live
together and you know for at least two
years because we mix them up you know
and you can't really choose to live and
spend all your time with people who are
like yourselves and because we put so
much resources into the dining-hall
community and you know after our evening
a buttery community students are really
always find themselves in settings where
they can meet people who are different
from themselves and and hear their
different perspectives and you know and
sometimes it can be tense but but at
least where people are in conversation
and and so coupled with the programs
that Kim has described that we're
working hard to develop I think we are
in a good position to address this it is
a very high priority for us okay woman
right there Pat Williams class of 71 I
was in Pearson drunken parties at Yale
have gotten a lot of publicity lately
and which parties sorry could you say
that again and I'm wondering what
attention is paid to that aspect of
substance abuse on campus we have we do
a lot of training for students when they
initially come in about our policies and
we have a number of students on campus
who they're called a communication
consent corney's to talk a little bit
about how a party effectively and work
with student organizations to make sure
that they're doing something
appropriately effectively meaning safely
sometimes what we find out is that when
they're probably on campus they're
actually well done but or and they're
safe but when students go off campus
that's where we have more problems so
we're spending a lot more time with
eternities and sororities mostly
fraternities to have conversation with
them about what our expectation
and monitoring them in very different
ways but we're also spending a lot of
time frankly with the students
themselves to make sure they're looking
out for each other and they understand
how to how to party a little bit more
safely so we haven't had as many issues
on campus and in fact one of the one of
the innovations that Marvin did this
year was to have a huge party the first
weekend of the first weekend that the
first year's class came on so all of all
of campus was across campus was taken
over Oh Oh campus our old campus was
taken over for something we call the
Bulldog bash which is something we've
done for two years running which is a
party that we throw with the Schwartzman
Center and Marvins team throws which has
five acts going from 9:30 to 2 p.m. to 2
a.m. to 2 p.m. and it does have a beer
garden where you have two older older
students can go in including graduate
students lots of food and basically
there's so much fun that nobody actually
ever goes away from that so they have an
experience of having a really good that
first party being really really fun
meeting people in a safe environment and
having better sets of ideas about how to
how to party more safely other what
other places so we're trying to help
again programming good modeling and a
lot of conversations with students that
we think might be problematic early on I
was a college head for nine years
and I've run many events with alcohol
beer and wine for my senior students and
I've not had a single student misbehave
or get sick at any of the events that I
hosted and what this told me was that if
if we can throw a party that serves
alcohol and treat the students like
adults the young adults that they are
and then they respond and act
responsibly as well the big problem is
that the drinking age of 21 forces our
students to have these underground under
supervised parties which are happening
off-campus and that has just been a real
big challenge to address and regulate
that said just on the notion of bulldog
bash party we're going to do a miniature
version of that for you all tonight on
old campus
at 9:00 p.m. and to help you model they
bring your ID yeah the party will be
drawing so please a pregame before you
arrive we have three minutes so I'm
going to take try to get to two
questions
something that you really want to ask of
this panel yep right back there yes you
so my name is Sara Fox I'm class of 73
we certainly were at Yale during what
you could call a hyper politicized time
but one of the things that's been
striking to me as we've walked around
the campus is how tranquil it is how
quiet it is you don't see political
posters you don't see anything about
political events there was as millions
of people around the world were
demonstrating on Climate Change
yesterday there was a little if there
were 35 people out in front of Stirling
library during a little rally they were
out on the green and that's where Yale
students were so anyway so that's my
question I guess just what is the sense
now about sort of political activism at
Yale has that changed about women
particularly at a time now where certain
aspects of women's rights seem to be
very much under threat what is your
sense of how the student body feels
about itself it's engaged in the world I
think we have a highly engaged student
body across the board in a lot of ways
the reason why you don't see posters is
because everything's on the internet
right now so they just they do Facebook
they think they connect with each other
that way it's less posters but this is a
you know certainly if you've been here
first of all there's sleeping's that's
why you don't really see the print now
but for the last couple of years
certainly they have been very much in
the mix many of them are spending a lot
of time off-campus and campaigns there
they're doing work
you know in legal legal organizations
but we have a very politically savvy
socially responsible group of students
who represent a broad range of views so
don't let the tranquility which actually
by the way I enjoy right now as a Dean
of Students don't let that fool you
because they're they're very much
active very active and I think you would
be proud that they are still carrying on
the tradition of being of service in a
variety of ways in a variety of
countries actually I would say so
so they are definitely would you agree
yeah as a former college president the
only thing I would say is I it was
always great when our students were
focusing their political activities
against the national issues outside the
college and not necessarily against the
administration exactly there's someone
over here who's been trying yeah right
here right in front yes
no I thank you Ruth Gemmell more 71 I'm
just curious about the question of
leadership and what happens to people
after they leave here and how you define
that these days particularly with the
emphasis on pre-professional partly
because of the cost of living cost of
college a lot of more students are on
financial aid so like everybody does
what they do here and then they go work
for whoever can pay them the most so I
just since we talked about leadership
how do you define it now so we track
what students are doing after graduation
very carefully we have good statistics
starting from the class of 2013 and so
for that class we even have data from
five years out you know basically where
I think we can be very proud of our our
young alumni that they you know that
they engage very broadly including in
many areas of public service arts
nonprofits to further encourage that
president's a Levay approved this new
program called domestic summer awards
which will pay students on financially
to work for a nonprofit organization
over the summers so that so that these
financial concerns would not constrain
the types of education and experiences
that they would pursue while they're
here at Yale and we're seeing the impact
you know I think we're gonna see the
impact of that continue even after
graduation and also just one other
additional statistic about our students
is that a lot of them go work but but by
five years out from graduation over half
of them come do some form of graduate or
professional school education so I think
that's a pretty cool and Yale's
financial aid policies are incredibly
generous and so students are able to
graduate without loan loan burdens so
those do not constrain decisions about
what they can do after then just very
quickly do you think the definition of
leadership has changed with women being
so much a part of Yale and or is it the
measures are still the same and women or
meeting or exceeding those measures you
know I asked this question of my site a
lot of students work in my office about
what constitute leadership at Yale
College and what they said is you know
we typically think of leadership
positions on campus as being the head of
the ydn YCC those organizations and most
recently the most recent woman who was
head of the YCC was actually just last
year and I think they've been a ten year
hiatus since the last woman who was a
head of it but most of the students
would say that yes those organizations
are wonderful but what they see as
leadership now our leadership of the in
the six hundred organizations that we
now have leadership on issues of social
justice and a lot of the things that are
really moving the campus in ways that
sometimes are uncomfortable for us are
really being led by women and honestly
women of color are really stepping into
the place talk about intersectionality
so I think for this generation the
concept of leader is broader than we
would typically say and that most
students see themselves as being leaders
in some way shape or form mostly because
they want to they all want to make some
kind of an impact
and what I find what I think the shift
has been is actually they want to make
an impact at home so many more of them
are going back home to make an impact
that's probably the shift and that's
where they see their leadership where
leadership has a long and strange
history if you think about it everyone
smirks if you say a thousand well
leaders but everyone knows a school like
Yale doesn't just accept some students
who tries to develop the talent of
students who are going to have
disproportionate impact but also these
students have lived with pressure to
apply to a college nowadays you have to
have been the president of at least
three clubs in high school and say
that's to say you've been pushed into a
certain definition of what leadership is
which means I have the the foremost role
I have I have a certain a certain
prestige or something of that sort I
think by the time people get out and in
life they understand that's not really
what leadership was about it wasn't
about the position you held it's about
thinking about how people take their
gifts and go have a disproportional
impact how they make other people
smarter how they ask more interesting
questions how they make people think
that impossible ideas might be less
impossible than they appear and you know
if I look in this room and see people
who I can see with careers in medicine
with careers in architecture with
careers in academics the world needs all
of those people
it doesn't need everyone to be the
president of those things but it needs
people to be the leader in more or less
the sense I have described I think
students would agree I think they say
leadership is service that's a great
note to end on thank you everyone for
being here and thank you panelist